welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham Aziz and today
I have a very special guest who's flown
all the way from Brazil the most
traveled air recruitment rollercoaster
guest today I'm joined by Ricardo
Bevilaqua that was okay wasn't that the
paper yet
I've been practicing that for about two
minutes before I did that and who is the
global CEO of a recruitment business
called g4 global partners and really
excited to have you Ricard and I think
we're a great place to start would be I
think you'd do it justice in terms of an
introductory to you and your business
let's start there yeah thank you very
much Hisham for being part of this very
interesting we heard a lot of good
things about you through our team in
Miami so this is a pretty well known
program in the US that's exciting
hopefully we can add value here for all
the recruiters that are listening to it
to this quick info about g4 so we are an
international search firm we operate
right now in 50 countries fifty fifty
five zero we have hired in more than 180
cities worldwide 80 people working for
us right now and the interesting thing
is that we have approximately 350 active
clients out of these 250 active clients
we work a lot on the private equity
industry and their portfolio companies
and the interesting thing is that we do
the specialized recruitment we also do
the market mappings yeah we do
assessments yeah and we now started to
do some of the temp services okay some
more contracts ten more contracts yeah
yeah and just to finalize that then and
then how many associate you located in
different parts of the world so where
where do you how many offices do you
have and in what locations perfect so
the majority of our offices right now
are in Latin America
okay simply because when we decided to
expand this was the region where there
was less competition easier to build up
the business at the time so we have two
offices in Brazil Sao Paulo and Rio we
have an office in Buenos Aires Argentina
one office in Santiago Chile okay one
office in Lima Peru yeah
one office in Bogota Colombia one office
in Mexico City and then North America we
have an office in Miami Florida and in
Vancouver Canada okay we have an office
in London yeah
the UK and we are two about to open in
Milan Italy and New York City well so
I've gotten on pretty busy father pretty
busy
exactly okay and so just to sort of
finalize that then and this business you
started by yourself I'd like you this
sole owner of this business or did you
start with another person yes so that's
that's a really good question we started
this business eight years ago
approximately as I was telling you I
don't count the years and pressure
exactly I don't put pressure on this and
we built this business when we started
with actually three or four other
partners at the time okay
and when we decided the name I actually
thought about GE due to the fact that we
were going to be global yeah and for as
you know for force for places of the
world
you know before exactly so that's why
god I'm gonna have a partner so we had
actually one partner in Sao Paulo and we
actually had two partners in Rio so we
were a total of four okay but when we
opened the business we started at the
same time in Sao Paulo Rio Santiago
Chile and Miami Florida
okay I was living in Miami at the time
and you're now the global CEO of this
and exactly okay so before we go into
that because I'm really excited to go
into that journey we're always like to
start on this show is how did
kado into the lovely world of
recruitment how does that happen that's
that's quite an interesting story
because I've been in this business now
for 19 years and a half
I'm offering a lot for 26 yeah yeah I
[Music]
don't know you know like in the u.s.
sometimes you cannot speak about this
but like I'm 45 years old when I started
in this business
everyone at 45 by the way well thank you
thank you it's the sentence but
basically I started when I was 26 years
old and I've been in this business for
19 years the interesting thing that I
always like to say is that since I'm 26
I've never worked again well as I have
passion for what I do really no I don't
consider this work and the the best part
of this is that I started my career my
professional career in Sao Paulo okay in
a really nice job and is that what you
see sorry so it's kinda exactly yeah so
basically I was born and raised in Sao
Paulo Brazil
my parents are Brazilian my father he's
half brazilian half Italian but I was I
studied in American school I had a like
maybe a lot of the American culture
since I was young and I had a chance to
live in the US for six months I lived in
Portland Oregon oh wow
but my first dream was I wanted to be a
football player right and I was actually
pretty good
when we're talking about him for hey no
no no we're talking about like soca I
would probably be playing like man city
or really or something like that good
yeah I was I was pretty good I was
pretty good
I was I was forward ready yeah I was
forward yeah pretty good that was your
first call that was my first call right
so the thing is that in in I had to stop
playing football to to work they had to
work and I got a pretty good job at
Citibank okay and some problem it was a
pretty nice job because first I started
and that's the interesting piece I did
an internship in the HR department
recruiting people okay for sushi banks
that forces lot corporate and you
allowed a corporate
creates a right exactly but as an intern
yeah and this was not expected this was
not what I thought I would do but I
loved it
and it was quite interesting because in
the person that hired me at the time and
City this lady I think she was simply
you know she had too many things to do
so she was simply letting me do my job
and but I didn't have any training well
starts in the deep end exactly so I
stayed there for six months and it was
interesting because one day and this is
a nice story to say because one day I
sat down in a table in Citibank
to have lunch and there was this
director sitting down by my side and I
was just speaking to my friends that
were other interns about you know my
career what I was doing and the fact
that I spoke English I wanted more so
this guy approaches me and he starts
speaking to me and asking me about like
hey what do you do I heard you study in
American school blah blah blah bottom
line this guy was the head of the audit
team for Latin America and he invited me
during this lunch to move from HR and to
work in audit and I said I'm moving
forward so I was I know that was this
recruitment know was order literally
working in the audit team okay so it was
quite funny because I didn't have any
type of experience yeah but I was
Yutaka yeah with a lot of energy willing
to learn very if I could say maybe I
hadn't made me this sympathetic approach
and he thought it would be good to have
this in the oddity okay so I worked with
with them for basically two years of my
life okay until I said you know what I
want to move to a sales position and I
went to work in the private banking
business okay and this was very nice
because the private banking business and
Citibank at the time was I would say
considered one of the best jobs to have
a hobby I said well you know in the
industry he didn't find that worth
individuals and he's
okay so this is where the doors open to
me and I started to understand like the
business reality exactly and I was not
in the front completely because I was
supporting the banker okay so I was not
running the show yeah but it was was a
pretty nice opportunity to start
understanding you know like how to sell
how to position yourself how to
communicate with these high net-worth
individuals that can be very very tough
yeah for sure no in a conversation but
the problem was that I hated the job
because I was not running the show and I
wanted to be in the front line yeah so
did you me a lot of high net-worth for
critters not really not recruitment
business owner came in exactly exactly
so the interesting piece of all this
before talking about how I got in is
that I honestly was not a successful
person from a professional standpoint I
had worked in HR for a short period of
time then I worked in audits but not
with a bright future and then I moved to
private banking where I also was not
having a bright future there I was an
assistance being part of the meetings
but not running the show so so when I
look back today I really think that I
had three years of my life three years
and a half which were okay yeah but that
helped me a lot to understand what I
didn't want to do yeah but he didn't
want it yeah he's gone right when you
died exactly and especially when I look
back today I would never work in a bank
again really like it was not I think
it's like great I think there's a lot of
qualified people that can do the job
much better than I did yeah there how
did you get into agreement after that
so the interesting thing is that I was
working for Citibank on the private
banking team and one day a friend of
mine that was an intern with me in the
audit team he moved to a cards business
okay like a Visa MasterCard in Brazil
and he applied to a job through
monster.com this was year 2000 and this
job was to work for Michael page Michael
Page the big British the white sharks
yeah you know the whites of the UK they
were they were starting their business
in Latin America they didn't have
anything in Latin America so this friend
of mine he joined the business yeah he
went to be trained in France for a
period of time yeah and when he got back
they said hey we want to hire somebody
to build up the banking business for us
and he thought about me and he said hey
come and meet what the industry yeah he
was in the finance and accounting team
yeah and and basically there was nobody
in banking so he called me in he said
hey you know I have this opportunity
with with this company and it was
interesting there was nothing about the
company there was not an office I was
going to meet two French guys very nice
guys by the way and I said you know what
I want to talk to those guys so I went
for the first meeting and never forgot
this because and we can speak about this
later you know like the dress code I
always use blue suits you know red ties
blue ties you know like much more like
of McKinsey environments I think that
the recruiters need to you transmit the
credibility and I remember going to this
first meeting with like a light brown
suits yeah I was like completely dressed
like if I was I don't know like an
accountant yeah or doing something that
was not really the recruiting business
but I did pretty well okay
I was approved yeah so you guys know I
got the job and I know you stay at
Michael Page fault so I stayed in
Michael page for four years I need to
see it I need to see it was very
exciting yeah yeah this isn't it from
scratch basically basically from scratch
but it was quite interesting to say that
page is probably one of the best
companies for you to learn and
understand how long is
sell yeah a little great great training
if you have the right managers it could
be a great culture yeah
great brand well great brands of the
although it's not a scratch you've got a
big brands of lenity I always say like I
have I like to talk about the good
things about my former employer yes for
sure so I learned a lot
the head of a page that today manages
you know Latin America and I believe
Africa yeah he's still a friend of mine
also so I learned a lot so how many how
many years did you was you a recruiter
before you started g4 yeah so
interesting question so I stayed in page
for four years in page I was if I could
say clever to work in the banking
business and then I went to their core
business which was the finance and
accounting business and then I decided
to launch the marketing and sales
business okay so basically in a question
of four years I had a pretty good
overview of different of different
markets yeah that I could hire yeah
Renea was out on vacation and this big
known interpreter from from another
company he calls me he had the the
largest if I could say job website in
Brazil in the sword cattle I got time
okay and he sold this website to a New
York private equity fund for 50 million
dollars uh-huh so this guy calls me in
one day remember vote you know no he
didn't know me but he was very clever
he would go to the clients and say hey
who are the sharpest recruiters from my
page and four or five clients talked
about my name and he said you know what
I want you to join so he made me an
offer and I said no and then he made me
a second offer I said no no I don't
think it's the right time and then on
the third offer I said you know what I'm
gonna move it I wanna I wanna give it a
try I was thirty years old
yeah I'm what suppose it was you selling
the job or for people to use the job
site no basically I was opening
a recruitment firm to compete with
Michael Page already yes so he had the
money yeah I had the stamina you know I
had the energy so basically he said look
I'm gonna give you 10% of the business
and I will have 90% in the beginning as
you grow I give you more so bottom line
I build a business from scratch in two
years we have we had 70 people Wow we
were billing figures of today probably
like 15 to 20 million dollars really and
we sold the business what markets do you
did so we were focused in Sao Paulo and
in Rio
yeah and we were basically focused in
engineering yeah Finance and Accounting
yeah HR and tech Wow so it was
interesting because we were getting
pretty good volumes of business Brazil
was so when Tiger global came in to buy
his online business he sold it together
with the wrong business
exactly I didn't want to send sell it at
the time yeah but it was the best thing
that happened to me because I had a
chance to with all the knowledge that I
had I had six to seven years of
experience I went to the United States
yeah with a business plan mm-hmm and I
sold it to Robert Half Wow
so exactly so Robert Half yeah yeah
another exactly and and the interesting
piece of this story is that I was a 32
year old guy with no fear
I simply build up a business plan I had
met somebody from Robert Half in
recruiters events in Washington and
actually sorry in New York City
yeah because I was making a lot of
questions in this event you know it was
a small event like 50 recruiter yeah and
I was asking questions trying to
understand global perspectives and then
during a coffee break this guy
approached me and says hey so were you
from Brazil blah blah she says hey I'm
from Robert Half give me your card
so we kept a card and when we sold the
business in Sao Paulo
I approached this guy and said look I
have a business plan would you guys be
interested in doing business
he said come to Washington I took a
flight went to Washington explained what
I was doing so he said well I'm gonna
speak to the guys I come back to Brazil
the next day he sends me an email saying
could you now go to California well and
speak to the global CEO
yeah and I said you know what I'm doing
that so I build up a business plan sit
down with the Global CEO sell him the
idea of Brazil yeah three months later
we were building the business in Brazil
really and we build the business or not
no no this is already Robert Half so
this is the Brazilian arm of Robert Half
and you put together a business plan
okay exactly he said that how long for
so I was the Latin managing director
based out of the US for four years well
so we build a business from scratch how
did that go really well the business was
was running really well Robert is a
powerhouse yeah for sure honey people
did you go out - oh we had probably 60
70 the same size and it was a similar
sort of markets to the previous company
no really the the interesting pieces so
if I if I make a quick comparison I
would say Michael Page is where I
learned how to sell yeah and to market
yeah Robert Half is the place where you
know how to manage a business manager
business so Michael Page is by far the
best for sales yeah and marketing yeah
yeah but Robert Half is extremely good
in policies procedures KPIs so that's
amazing yeah but but in my opinion
Robert Half is maybe too big yeah and I
was too small yeah and the company and
this is one of the factors I decided to
leave they are a probably a five billion
dollar business actually probably out of
the five billion dollars they're like
four hundred million dollars in the
recruitment business
and the rest is temp yeah and that's not
exactly where I believe I'm I'm situated
I'm more of the consulting type of
profile that wants to sit down and and
and less less maybe transactional and
more of a global if I could say okay so
after that after that on g4 was born so
when when I left Robert Half yeah I had
to stick to the non-compete yeah yeah
that was and and that's something that
everybody wants to know always make sure
you you read the contract and sign the
contract had a yeah so I had a one full
year that was very interesting it was
good because I had a chance to build up
a business plan yeah ready fing discuss
with a lot of people find investors so
did you know when they invested oh yeah
so we got private investors and that's
what's the interesting piece because I
had the courage I had the money to do it
on my own yeah but I wanted to be backed
up if necessary why simply because you
know at the end of the day I always
understood that you know it's it's the
same amount of energy if you want to
think big or if you want to think small
yeah and I wanted to think big and I
wanted to make sure that we could do
something very different from what most
of the people want to do yeah from your
experience yeah okay what an amazing
story so from what from from what we
just heard that I feel like you've had
this sort of perfect grounding an
experience to get you to the point of
starting your own recruitment business I
think that's fair to say right far from
being perfect
[Laughter]
a lot of people a lot of people
particularly UK market typically will
there'll be a recruiter under someone so
I let some were a recruiter for Ricardo
at Robert Half typically a lot of people
will start their own business from that
experience but obviously you had the
experience or putting a business plan
together launching a complete new part
of the business so from from what you
just shared that I just feel like that
must be
some great experience to help you
understand how to and how not to
approach G fall in the business that
you're obviously building now so so
that's now what eight years on now from
that from you deciding to start that
yeah exactly
what I can say is I'm humbled enough to
know and understand that we need to
learn every day yeah for sure and I even
I would say I forced myself to learn new
things every day yeah the recruiting
business and I admire a lot the
recruiters because the recruiting
business is very tough we have hard days
you have long days we have a lot of nose
I think specially in the UK we have a
lot of positive things and a lot of
negative things positive things is most
of the companies are used to using
recruiters yeah definitely so you don't
need to educate a market and you know
like when I think about like Latin
America we need to educate the market
really oh my god yeah you need to
educate the market it's it's not easy
but at the same time you know when I
look into the UK people are very
straightforward here with the recruiters
sometimes you know like many be a
recruiter here is tough some sometimes
people they simply don't want to speak
to you due to past doesn't have the best
reputation exactly which does not happen
in Latin usually people are very open to
speak to a recruiter they're very open
for a phone conversation to start so you
know we need a balance and we need we
need to understand the differences of
each one of the markets so what I really
like to do Ricardo is just lets the
loads of questions I'll ask you but I
think let's just sort of just break down
the business journey just everyone's
been at benefit so so you put together
his business plan you get you get
investment to start this business you
launch at the same time as you said so
you launched in where was you sorry
when you launch this business we're sure
when we started the business we started
in San Paulo and Rio in Brazil and
Brazil Santiago in Chile and
I am using mine in the yes so let's just
talk about so the let's break it to the
first year and G for what was that like
how difficult was that tough yeah we had
to rebuild a brand actually build up a
brand I had my credibility yeah to use
because I had worked and hired in these
four different cities but it was tough
you know you need to build this from
scratch you need a go to the clients and
use your name and your credibility to
bring business for you and remember I
was one year out of the market without
do you have to tighten you have to try
and rekindle your networking connections
after a year exactly exactly so it was a
lot on my energy and what I had to do in
the first year I would even say there
was maybe the first three or four years
and now the business has changed yeah
quite dramatically
so the first three or four years it was
a lot of building relationships again
building your credibility
under the new g4 brand exact love that
was being driven by you exactly and we
need to remember as recruiters that you
know you need to open new doors every
day yeah but you need to make sure that
you keep the ones that you opened yeah
still open for you to do business you
know I think there's a fine balance
there right I had someone not too long
ago that yeah because in the UK business
developments of winning new business can
be really challenging part for a lot of
recruiters right so picking up the phone
and cold calling opening doors right
this is the most difficult difficult Bay
as you quite rightly said I think if you
have but you also want to be aware of
you don't to be complacent right in
terms of the relationships you have one
client that spend $100,000 of your last
year man that spending fifty nine fifty
thousand dollars this year right and
that's interesting so you serve those
three four years he was always focusing
on your existing relationships and
opening new doors exactly yeah I think
it interesting to mention if I may is
that you know like
as we have opened our global business
yeah I could say that half of what we
did was planned okay and half of what we
did was not planned okay so what do I
mean by that that's that's quite
interesting so we've decided to open in
Italy for example in Milan without
having this plant but we have three or
four clients that have turned out to be
global clients with solid operations in
Milan
yeah and that's how we got in Milan okay
now when we decided to move to London or
we decided to now move aggressively to
New York it's simply because there's a
lot of opportunities in the financial
markets or in specific industries which
we believe we can add value mm-hmm so
you have some some parts of our
expansion which are unplanned yeah you
love opportunity but the opportunities
show up and we have in other cases you
know cities and and in markets that we
want to really do business so because we
know about it so so when did you when
did you start the global expansion how
long into the g4 journey was it two
three years and was it still in the
beginning places that you start the
business when did you start expanding
globally I think we had the global
mindset since the beginning okay so you
have the monster that's great all the
mindset and important to mention the
global mindset starts on who we hire so
just to give you a quick example every
recruiter that we hire we look into a
few key things one is speaking more than
one language well this is the first
thing yeah so we always look for that
the second key thing is international
exposure so what do I mean by this if
I'm hiring somebody based out of London
I either want to make sure that this
person has lived in a different country
or has been exposed to multiple
countries to understand multiple
cultures
so this has been very important for us
since the beginning and as we built our
business just to give you some thought
we have today people from probably 15
different countries that's amazing and
we probably speak 10 or 12 different
languages yeah that's really interesting
so from day one your glut your global
mindset as men that you've when you're
hiring people if your business you've
had those things in mind
that's really interesting when do you
actually start opening our offices at
what point what did you have that if
this was part of your plan but what I
think will be really good to sort of get
your thoughts on is if I'm listening
right now and I'm thinking or growing my
business internationally what are some
of the sort of obviously can always be
planned as you just said but I think
what are some of the sort of key may be
metrics or key sort of milestones that
you hit as a business to go right we're
ready to expand a globally or whatever
to go I mean what are some of the things
that you ensure that you got to or the
milestones that you got to that sort of
gave you real confidence in growing your
recruitment business globally and if in
there so yeah so there's a few a few key
things okay I think that if I'm gonna
probably say about what is my mindset
yeah open businesses today because I've
learned a lot I had and I think I can
say this here I had some really this big
disappointments yeah I had a big
disappointment when we opened Germany
okay we open an office in Berlin yeah it
was a disaster yeah I hired a recruiter
there which was a really good recruiter
but then we discovered that he didn't
really speak German was living there
with his fiance he was a recruiter with
a lot of experience in the UK he had
some German but not as fluent as we
needed and we didn't check that yeah so
this type of mistake happens but it was
an opportunistic hire at the time we
also had a really bad experience the
first time we got in Mexico we hired the
wrong recruiter which didn't show up for
yeah so it's interesting to mention this
because you know these things will
happen yeah you know that big fat asian
and honestly I've heard worse stories
than this okay now we had some really
great experiences we hired somebody in
Columbia somebody in Peru people that do
great jobs we have a really good job a
good team right now in um in Miami we
found some really good people in London
but this takes time you know so
importance if you think about expansion
you need to take a few things into
accounts from a financial perspective
understands how much money you need to
invest and make sure you have money to
keep the business moving if not growing
for at least one year
so yes before you think about open
another office have you got the funds
and cash flow to for at least a year
we're done so give yourself at least a
year runway exactly the second thing
don't think you're gonna make money in
the short term don't think you're gonna
bring in dividends to your HQ in a first
year just think about like making money
and reinvesting this money in the
business so from a financial aspect I
would say this the second important
thing from a location standpoint make
sure you can be there
that you can be there at least three or
four times a year okay no this is a
common mistake people say oh you know
what I'm gonna expand to you know a
different city mm-hmm but maybe it's too
far for you maybe you don't really have
the time or the availability to visit
and stay there for a full week and to
get to understand the culture to visit
the clients so you need to make sure you
have this the third thing in which I
consider is the most important pieces
make sure you interview and have a
really good process of bringing talent
for your team make sure you understand
the culture make sure you
ask the questions visit the person more
than once you know like we've we've
already hired people through skype big
mistake really
exactly I'm gonna give an example today
I've regrouped with the candidate that
I've interviewed three months ago in
London and I regrouped with this person
again it was excellent because I had a
few things that I needed to check in and
I actually had a different perception of
this person after three months you know
this is important to take decisions so
we even though the pace of our industry
is super you know aggressive we're fast
paced we need to make sure that we hire
slowly when we're hiring for other we
need to make sure exactly that we're
taking the right decisions because then
you're adding a headcount and opening an
office you know in a different country
where sometimes you are three hours ten
hours away yeah and you need to make
sure that you're able to manage this
yeah you know really that's really
interesting so is it fair to say then a
lot of your sort of global expansion
strategy has been finding and
cultivating really relationships with
recruiters that can open offices in in
obviously different countries right yeah
that fair yeah is that mean since I've
been the majority at the time where
you've identified someone or you've
ended up speaking to someone and then
you and then you've cultivated that
relationship for them to go right we're
gonna start a G for recruitment business
here in London or whatever it may be
yeah if I could save like four for those
of you that are listening to this and
once you expand your businesses
understand that hiring internally is one
of the most important activities that
you will have yeah I invest personally
thirty percent of my time really
interviewing candidates Wow and I
interview for open jobs that we have
yeah or also on a proactive basis yeah
so quick example
in the next two days here in London I'm
interviewing two three candidates for us
we don't have the open head counts but I
want to interview because maybe we can
open if the people are good yeah you
know in meal on Thursday and Friday I'm
interviewing eight candidates well next
week in Rio I'm interviewing another
four or five candidates since you've
always had the mindset of always hiring
exactly how you not being reactive never
exactly because you know finding the
best people takes a lot of time yeah so
we established a culture that we don't
wait to have an open position yeah to
then start hiring people yeah we are
actively looking for good people and we
have the ability today we've grown the
business to a size that we have the
ability to as we find good people you
know open the jobs and bring them in so
this is a good thing so they're our
first four years as you asked me were
very tough you know like we had to you
know personally go visit the clients
build up a brand build up a credibility
and now we have this and this helps us
to bring new talents you know gaining a
momentum which is going important for us
what I'd love to get your focus on is
like how how difficult is it to trust
someone they obviously you have
specially if you're hiring them as a
brand new hire of she would have met
them a couple of times interview these
types of things for then so if you've
met with me and we recognize together
there I think I'm someone that can open
a London part of your business how hard
is it how difficult is it to trust that
person
yeah well have you dealt with that
because that must be hard right because
a lot of people in the UK the
conversation I had has been obviously
and the challenges all the things that
worried about is so if I'm a like like
you started in Brazil if I started in
London and then I want to take my
business to Brazil I'm worried that the
culture that I've worked so hard to
build in the UK may not be taken to
Brazil if I don't hire something that
fully gets what we are yeah business
is yeah to have how view how have you
managed or have you sort of unable to
trust people to sort of live and breathe
the business that you bill that which
ultimately you're just hiring them to
get one does that make sense yeah so I'm
gonna put it in a in in in in from maybe
an interesting perspective here so while
we had lunch today I was speaking to the
team about you know the difference from
the Brits yeah and the Italians okay
they're very different
yeah and they're so close and so far
yeah you know you know it's close in a
sense of like you know from here to meal
and it's a two-hour flight but they're
they have completely different
perspectives you have you know work and
careers and so on so I think the first
thing that we need to understand is that
if you want to build up an international
business not necessarily a global
business you need to respect cultures
yeah you need to make sure that you
don't implement what you think is right
or what you think is uh you know your
style yeah you know like if I I always
say to people you know like sometimes
the the definition of speed or of
quality of life is completely different
if you ask a Brit or if you ask you know
the Asian yeah we're Latin Canary mom
exactly now of course you need to make
sure that you have similar values
in a similar culture here so and then
this comes to the trust piece of it so
what we learned is that to build trust
we need to make sure that we speak and
interact a lot yeah especially in the
beginning and that's why when we need a
higher people today we make sure that we
have multiple conversations so it starts
in the beginning with multiple
conversations and we're very transparent
in what we do I always say that I be
extremely transparent
and you don't like me then not being
transparent yeah and then you discover
who I am and then you don't like me I
prefer to have a no in the beginning by
you saying look you know what after what
we spoke I don't feel comfortable like I
don't hire you you don't waste your time
I don't waste my time
then hiring you and then suddenly you
discover something that you didn't like
yeah so we are very transparent in the
beginning and and as I am transparent
with you and I set up what we consider
are our standards of communication our
KPI is how you will work I want to make
sure that you're good with that and that
it makes sense for your career also I
think with this we start building
they're not really like that so just to
make it clear then from your experience
I think that's really interesting so
there's sort of non-negotiables of /
obviously obviously respecting the
culture you have to understand yeah what
work-life balance might be for an
Italian compared to a Brazilian sort of
thing what this sort of non-negotiable
is that you sort of now have if you're
expanding with people globally so you
said make sure the values are aligned
and then was anything else yes or non
negotiables great question so what I
would say today you want to think about
trust everything starts with
communication yeah
so there's always one thing I tell to
everybody yeah you want to work with us
be transparent yeah be honest yeah so I
will never or actually I will I can be
unhappy mm-hmm with you know bad news
yeah bad results yeah but I don't want
to be surprised
yeah sure I prefer to have the bad news
coming from you yeah or you know
something is wrong with the clients or I
didn't do my job in the best way that is
fine but I don't want to be surprised
yes the trust and transparency exactly
yeah you need to make sure that if your
be surprised by the person you've hired
trustus yeah is non-negotiable trust and
honesty from the gate exactly so so I
would say this is definitely the first
things you need to communicate the best
way I think also you know in in in the
day-to-day you need to make sure that
the results are showing up mmm you know
so I speak a lot about the results we
have weekly meetings with everybody
globally that we operate and they know
what their their KPIs are and we go
through the KPIs and I always give an
honest feedback yeah on a weekly basis
weekly basis so you have everybody
because weekly calls
so how do you communicate as a global
business is it free like zoom is it
through yeah so we have a system pretty
similar to zoom but we also use hangouts
yeah so on a weekly basis everyone what
regardless of Tom differences everyone
we have we have a specific time of the
day that every like for example every
business developer for example gets into
this specific call yeah
it's every Friday and we discuss results
and we also cross hell so it's talking
about results and cross selling
engineers to each other so let's say
somebody visited you know HSBC in the UK
and there's HSBC in New York City so the
business developer will say look I've
been to HSBC this this and this happened
and by the way hey New York team yeah
there's an opportunity here I visited
this guy this guy gave me this name in
New York and boom and how long have you
had that process because I feel like
that must be paramount so yeah this has
been going strongly in the last three
months oh wow
exactly it's quite new and it's amazing
the level of success it's amazing really
how did I how eyes yeah what yeah so
there's an interesting story so I'm a
very good very good friend of mine he
was the global CEO
Western Union Wow the money transfer
business and he told me once that they
transformed the financial and sales
analysis of Western Union by
implementing the weekly meeting the
weekly meeting so they said look we have
52 weekly meetings in a year and we go
you know one of 50 to 200 and so on so
they started doing that and it
completely transformed the business well
it was the what's the structure of the
me and nothing not be really valid so
basically we do it's of course like in
our case we have 15 BDS yeah so 15
people on the call and we we need to be
very straightforward and also it's a one
hour and a half call yeah so we start by
for example we say Chilean team let's go
one by one so basically what they say is
they go volume of meaty so Jess I
remember a number of meetings in a week
how many jobs in how many terms and
conditions that were sent to discuss
other jobs in yeah and then how many
meetings you have for next week yeah so
when they start with is the metrics that
you've identified that give you the best
chance of the result so they start there
exactly okay so they go through these
metrics yeah when the end these metrics
and then it's open for anybody in the
globe to ask questions yeah maybe
somebody in you know Canada might say
okay good so you visited this mining
company yeah in Chile which is a
Canadian company do you have a
connection or could you ask a name yeah
you start the cross how awesome so
everyone starts with this these are
results this week and then after every
one going through that there's an
opportunity for everyone's collaborate
and exactly okay three months in and
that's not a big impact huge impact
really uh like just just to give an idea
we get just from these weekly calls
we've increased probably fifty percent
the volume of jobs in really on a weekly
basis well and that's just by having
clear
acacia non-communication Kleiss yeah and
strongly working on on knock Russell
yeah yeah so what what I'd love to just
just may just maybe talk a bit about so
you you shared a bit about around the
sort of failures in some of the
countries but so you said three the
first three four years were really
challenging your in what year eight nine
now Eid nine yeah so how as you sort of
grown internationally how has this
impacted revenues and perfil and like an
actual profitability of a business
you'll clearly someone that obviously is
really interesting you said if you open
an international office then you need to
give yourself at least one year runway
of this business like don't think you're
gonna be taking those dividends and
these types of things that that's great
but how have what's been your yeah
what's been the sort of balancing out
with that and what's been the experience
of that so yeah talk a bit about that so
be good to just talk a bit about that
and that your experience in I guess
ensuring the profitability doesn't take
a massive hit every time you're growing
the business because you playing the
long game here right yeah so last year
our revenues were up 35 percent we
project a minimum of forty percent for
this year really but I honestly think we
could double the revenues will revenue
do last year ah we can't disclose that
really yeah yeah no but why don't we do
that we had last year three different PE
firms approaching us what to buy uh to
buy one of them wanted to buy a hundred
percent which was quite strange honestly
because they were like we want to buy
you guys and I'm not gonna manager John
it's um
I can't disclose this all simply because
I would need to have some approval from
but basically so we grew getting back we
grew 35 percent we want to grow between
40 and 50 percent this year but we
clearly think we can double revenues and
that we've been profitable which is the
most
yes awesome always but but um you know
if I think about like our expansion
strategy today is going to markets which
the currency is either stable or strong
yeah so why am I saying this because
like we have an experience of being in a
market like Argentina which is a super
unstable market I would probably not go
to the African markets right now I would
be cautious about going to you know
let's say Eastern Europe I would be very
cautious with that but I would be very
focused and moving to you know Germany
where we have a lot to do getting more
into the domestic market of the United
States yeah so if I could give a piece
of advice and if you want to start your
international expansion go to solid
markets go to markets where the currency
is stable or at least the economics are
there yeah you know before trying to do
or to expand to places which can be
extremely tough and I simply say this
because you know like we are hiring
right now for example for Nigeria and I
spoke to a recruiter that said hey you
know like my strategy here is to to open
in Mozambique Morocco like tough tough
tough markets in which you know when you
think about you know like from a revenue
perspective and pounce yeah maybe it's
irrelevant yeah so it sounds simple but
okay that mean is there any sort of key
things and that I guess and they can
always change content these types of
things but any key any key things you
always look for that sort of gives you a
really good indication or confidence
that it's a strong market and any key
things that you always look for all yeah
not really so one of the things I want
to always make sure is are there
recruiters there
and it's interesting because the more
recruiters and the more professional the
markets the better for us because this
means that you have well educated
clients yeah my son that are used to
using recruiters so it makes your life
easier you know your pitch gets better I
need to remember that you know most of
our competitors are the boutique firms
in each one of the cities that we
operate yeah and we bring in our edges
at the end of the day is that we're a
global firm that can bring you know many
candidates that not necessarily are in
London or in Rio and that might be
outside of these cities you're willing
to come back or willing to work and
build their careers yeah with the
companies in these cities okay so over
the last sort of a couple years then I
think you mentioned a bit around the
failures I think you've been really sort
of open and transparent around your
approaches and these types of things but
what would have been would have been
some of the biggest challenges over the
last four or so years then so yeah what
have been some of the biggest challenges
of your as you really expanding this
business globally what are some of the
challenges that I would say it's all
about the people really at the end of
the day the people for your business
exactly so and for the clients too but
you know like we have as I mentioned 80
people today yeah we could easily have
120 meaning we could be 50% bigger than
we are today but we learned that finding
the right people willing to work in a
tough industry like the recruiting
industry is not easy so we really take
time in finding this talent and quick
example we've opened Bogota
we could have weather in Colombia okay
so we could have 10 people in Bogota
yeah we're far from having ten people
because simply we are interviewing and
interviewing and interviewing there and
we have Helen
I high bar high bar exactly so it takes
time so how have you go better that um
how have you go have you improved with
your chances so important things that we
do first of all we don't make this a
process with too many steps or too many
interviews yeah
but we make sure that the line manager
yeah of the lurch is exactly which is
the most interesting interested part of
of the process of course interviews the
candidates then from this we take to our
talent acquisition team we have a global
gonna size you have Medicaid resource
exactly okay so we go to HR to our local
HR and then we put usually director
interviewing there's candidates and then
I interview the candidates I interview
everybody so usually we have four
minimum of four people interviewing
these candidates now what we also do is
we do an assessment so we usually apply
Hogan was that you have a personality
test I like a psychometric test exactly
so based on the report we take a
decision about hire person or not Pat
look into and that that's a good
question we've been doing this for the
last year because that's come out
recently that people have done that and
it's had a big impact on making better
decisions exactly exactly
so our turnover has been going down
really exactly simply because we want to
make sure that we bring in the right
personality that we bring in the people
that that are in line with what we
consider are the values and the culture
of the business and have you have you
got cuz I can just clearly that will
definitely be the biggest chatter I mean
that's a bigger challenge for people
just in one country that alone for a
multinational business so have you got
different localized the right fit type
of people like I mean if you if you say
your job openings in Colombia right now
compared to your job openings in Miami
how'd it like how different those people
that trying to look for and how how
how do you communicate the g4 message
effectively but how different is the
local message to get my min or is it is
it different or is it the same well we
try to keep it the same
yeah but respecting respecting the car
you know the culture but like what do we
look for so if I think about personality
we're always looking for really good
communicators yeah so people that can
speak well but that can also listen
listen well you know and having good
listeners is a big challenge these days
yeah you know everybody knows how to
speak communicate you know do the
Instagram but you know like listening
and listening to what the client says or
to what an candidate says this is a big
piece of it the second thing that we
always look for is the level of energy
mm-hmm and we also look into how
organized is the person because this is
multitask
you know like recruiters have to speak
to candidates speak to clients and
organize the resumes organize the
reports so we look into these three
things every time mmm a part of the
global piece which is very important for
us and just quickly on that before I
before we finish I'd just love to talk
to you a bit about your experience on
just just managing all of this talking
about being organized in size just you
actually managing this business which
obviously it has its own challenges but
and what's gonna say what's the what's
the typical recruitment business model
in your offices is it this because so in
the UK the typical recruitment business
has been 360 right I don't know if that
sort of that context does that make
sense to you in terms of so if I'm a
real creature right now in the UK firm
typically my job will be multifaceted
where I have to pick up the phone to
speak to clients and open new doors and
I also have to speak to candidates and
and do both of those and spin those
plates right but what's interesting is
is and I think this is actually Khan
from America is that a lot of UK
businesses now are looking at having
teams completely dedicated business
developers so always open in door
new business right and then they have
teams that are completely dedicated to
sourcing and finding the candidates for
these jobs and then obviously those two
communicating effectively and having a
slick process that enables people to
have a real focus on these things so
yeah how what's the yeah what's the
typical have you got that in your
business or really yes always been like
that
no actually I would say that we're very
we're not rigid with this I think we
learned with time that you can have 100%
recruiters 100% PD's yeah and you can
have the 360 yeah yeah so you're
flexible with we're super flexy and we
give people the alternatives that unity
and and they decide what they want okay
why do we do that and maybe this is why
this is growing in the u.s. you have a
lot of turnover people leave the
business and one of the reasons that
people leave this business is because
the recruiter does not want to visit
visiting clients is super tough yeah
having to sell I don't add in a cold
calling is super tough and me and people
get scared about this and they said
executives get now on the other hand
sometimes you have the salespeople that
they don't let a recruit yet I don't do
this sourcing yeah exactly so we keep
and give the opportunity for people to
do what they really like and they're
good to do so this is our mother's up
around here if I could say so before we
finish so obviously we send obviously
before we start this you're a family man
yeah you've got four children three
three three I would love to have four
but three is a good number so let's just
like how how has grown in this business
we always have honest conversations on
this podcast so I guess before we
finished I'd love to just sort of you've
been very honest so I guess how how how
has been the sort of the balancing act
of Ricardo's actual life with growing
this business because there I mean I
can't even imagine the amount of plates
that you're spinning and
been really effective of communicating
and setting up processes we can
communicate with all the different
businesses and these sorts of things so
I guess yeah what's been your journey
with that ricardo for that mom yes
what's been your sort of experiencing
work-life balance growing this business
what's that being like for you and your
journey with that I would say that you
know it's it's that learning growing
changing mmm every day I would say that
I've been more effective now that I've
been in the last six months and
hopefully I'm gonna be better in the
following six months things that I
learned I work by the hour so every hour
of my day I need to accomplish specific
things so really so that's blacked out
in your daughter every hour
exactly so I'm very focused on what I
have to do by the hour this is something
I learned and kind of just say sorry to
button yeah so obviously I've been
engaging with your lovely colleagues and
it's a book in this podcast how involved
was you in that not all in terms of like
so these people really you got people
dedicated to managing your diary exactly
yeah lady efficient I have like a PA
yeah that takes care of my business life
and also even about my personal life
really so quickly haha
I had that for a year and a half Wow
which includes my personal life really a
year and a half now and how much of an
impact is huge yeah I'm gonna give an
example you know like I manage the
global business yeah I don't work on
weekends yeah like I don't know
literally like 7 7 p.m. Friday night
until you know like 5:00 a.m. Monday
morning yeah like I I don't need a yeah
I'm completely off I don't look to my
emails I can have time with my kids can
have time for me yeah which is important
yeah well but that that's something that
made made a pretty big change and and
just think about this
I literally fly
45 weeks of the year
fly fly and fly and plan on a plane 45
weeks of the year yeah I spent at the
most seven weeks of the year in my base
all the rest is yeah all the time so how
do you maximize that song one important
thing I learned a lot
you know while I'm in the plane this is
when I can usually relax and watch my
Netflix or my Amazon Prime yeah relax
yes this is when I send many what's up
messages yeah so like I and I learned
very important I don't text I sent the
voice mortgages so like I literally
spend sometimes like one hour preparing
the whatsapp messages for everybody and
when I land you know I just click send
or just get online yeah it's done it's
it's amazing how how my life has been
easier now using you know the what's up
for everything I have to do so it's
blocking out each hour of your time no
we need to focus on exactly yeah
obviously doing smart things on
obviously yeah time if you're flying a
lot and if an ounce that sort of really
impacted you personally in terms of sort
of keeping on top of everything and
managing this bill yeah there's there's
one thing that I've changed in my
management style every time I sit down
with a direct report we the direct
report will write down everybody we
discuss that everything that we
discussed some broad imminence exactly
and send it to me and to everybody that
was in the meeting okay so this keeps me
instead of me having to write down or
take a during a meeting you've got
someone else in the context of exactly I
can concentrate my time in making an
effective meeting and then I get all you
know that everything that happens to
like maybe rethink and
if something is missing then connect
again and what about what about your
mindset where does mindset fit into this
I've got a couple of questions that are
definitely on a speech about resilience
okay and and how important that is but
where I mean you from
you seem someone that's quite grounded
and sort of calm and what where did
where does mindset like what's been a
journey of mindset I mean in the UK
mental health and talking about your
sort of yeah talking about your mental
health for managing this and these types
of things is huge and a lot of people
struggle with it and in the UK
particularly so I guess mindset where
does this fit in for you and what would
have you done personally to work on your
mindset to help you manage all of this
yeah so there's a few things first when
I think about mindset I think about you
know me being a global person yeah so
you know I'm always interested about
people okay and interests and always
trying to learn new things now answering
your question a few things are very
important for me today so even though I
work by the hour I always try to put a
few things into my day so the first
thing I learned and I've been exercising
is that I wake up early yeah so usually
I try to wake up at 5:00 a.m. yeah I try
to read mm-hmm I try to exercise and I
always look into what are my personal
goals month and then I and then I go to
work then you and then you start looking
and then I start my day
exactly so this is something that it's
almost like I have one hour and I recall
that's on me that that's what my family
this is this is a video sample you know
exactly yeah the second thing that I
always make sure on my mindset is that
I've no I'm not influenced by social
media okay so I always make sure and
understand that you know like if you
look into an Instagram and you see
you know this person you know like
looking really good really healthy or
star in a yacht or in the private jet
you know I always understand that you
know great for them I don't feel bad
about me if I'm not you know comparing
this style of life I don't compare with
anybody and I need to be honest I
compared myself a lot they do a lot and
you know like with time you stop
comparing yourself you're just view and
you're building your story yeah so I
learned that I need to build my story
yeah some people will love it some
people maybe I love it do you become
more and more comfortable with that
exactly but I would say that at the end
of the day what I'm building here is a
story that I want to make sure that my
family my friends are proud of having me
as family or friends and building like
such an interesting story that's awesome
and what would you say then before I ask
you to cover questions on resilience
would you say sort of ensuring that you
give yourself that sort of time for self
care in the morning and and and have
those habits that's enable you to yeah
be more present with your staff family
yeah I feel like that's it's a great
anchor that's what is that part why you
do it so then you you know that you've
made that time for yourself so then when
you are with whoever the different
people are you are in your day you can
really be there because you know yeah
that's definitely yeah that's that's had
an impact on on me as well making sure I
have time for myself on in the morning
and couple of questions on resilience so
the reason why I marshal this is do kids
in in March and we're having so in in
November I hosted the very first live
podcast event and so hosting another one
in March in London and the topic is
cultivating resilience and going the
distance in recruitment so I'd love to
just get your thoughts and experience on
resilience and then I'll ask you the
final question and what you're excited
about because I know there's a few
things that you have planned and going
on this year so what is resilience in
recruitment mean to you Ricardo what
does it mean to you firstly and
standing that you're going to have a lot
of those mm more nose than yeses hmm
understanding that it will be tough yeah
it's not an easy easy path yeah
[Music]
understanding that it's long hours
understanding that it's difficult mmm
but at the same time having fun yeah
it's a being comes with the fat that's
not always gonna work out exactly but
yeah I always say that you know we need
to understand that there will be enough
and we need to expect that there will be
a no and that there will be difficulties
but if you do your job the yeses will
show up and the doors will be open
that's awesome so how has the importance
or need for resilience changed as the
industry is evolved that's a really good
question that's a really good question I
would say that you know we need to be
patient
hmm I think there's more competition I
think there's more and more lack of
challenge hmm this is a candidates
market this is not just a client's
market yeah so you know like when you
think about this and help me if I'm not
answering your question here but you
know in the beginning we were like wow
you know tough to find clients and
actually everybody needs to hire good
people so it's always that the right
people yeah you know candidates are
resistance to make the right move mmm
actually not to make the right move
resistant to move to move people around
a lot less actually so you you have
picky clients and you have picky
candidates yeah so the job of a
recruiter has been tougher record more
nice it's gonna say a nice exactly so
just got more challenging basically
which requires more rejection more nose
I think yeah last one on resilience Oh
I guess more so from you as a business
owner what what can people do to instill
more resilience in their teams I think
there's you need to educate the teams
hmm and you need to educate the teams by
telling each one of your staff members
that it's a tough job yeah
be transparent you need to be
transparent yeah you cannot tell you
know like that that they will expect
roses yeah on the way you actually need
to create the tough environment yeah and
maybe they will see it's not as tough as
you're creating it but if you don't say
and go and walk them through mmm since
the beginning they will fall apart
yeah because you know it's pretty hard
to deal with tough clients it's pretty
hard to to deal with candidates that
will tell you one thing and then do a
different thing
yeah you know so be resilient is you
know overcoming all this yeah but
especially in the beginning with people
that do not have this experience yeah
and do not understand where where
they're this will come from yeah you
need to be not like that and so before a
lot actually the last question really
enjoyed this ricotta and I think you've
been there gray and what what are you
excited about I was I always ask people
what what are you what they excited
about what you excited about in your
world what's going on in the g4 Empire
in 2020 what's going on well I mean I'm
first of all excited about about the
future and simply because you know when
you look back Lincoln in came and people
thought wow you know the recruiters are
out of business it's over far from being
over yeah I think the the industry is
well positioned we never had so many
opportunities to excel we need more
recruiters honestly we need more people
to find talents so I think the future
is bright every single country in the
world needs to have recruiting agencies
yeah
the labor market is transforming itself
mmm governments are understanding the
importance of you know having talented
people to generate more business you
know like when you see to what happened
in New York with Amazon and Google you
know New York fighting to have these
companies their understanding that they
will generate more jobs mm-hmm more
revenue mm-hmm so just think about this
impact in other cities in the world in
what can be done so it's I would say the
future is bright for everybody yeah I
think a big part of big mission in this
podcast Ricardo is so helping make
recruitment a career choice a lot of
people fall into it right and I think
that's that's a huge thing I think
there's so many great opportunities
recruitment can offer a lot of people
but it's for this can play a part in
helping people actually pick recruitment
because I think it can do a lot for
people and but know they're your cookies
will hey me bet you've got you've got
some exciting announcements in the
pipeline right you know I always say the
pizza is big everybody can get his or
her slice so just make sure that you
keep doing your job you know and my
marketing team you're telling me that I
need to remember everybody exactly
exactly with our global expansion soon
we will have a different brand so g4
will evolve change evolve change names
and yes this is coming this is coming
actually for a really good reason but
we're gonna announce this soon yeah yeah
last question one caller asks everyone
on this show is so you cannot you can
answer this question with a word the
phrase sentence whatever comes to mind
so it's the question is if if Ricardo
could communicate to every single
recruits are out there or recruitment
business owner they take on your advice
they'd listen they'd implement your
advice tomorrow
what would you say to these people if
they're all listening first of all focus
in your business don't focus on the
competitors mmm don't envy the
competitors just look at them if you
want to learn something new and get
better but focus on your business
the second thing don't have paradigms
you can build something which is maybe
much bigger than what you have today or
that is much more profitable than what
you have today so you just need a belief
in yourself and don't put any paradigms
on what you have to do I'm glad that
it's been a pleasure thank you my
pleasure thank you